I
N CAG THE
TEENRIRGH ADS TO TESTIFY AA SEN
EXOI DRAMATI ZUCKEERG
RNED TFA APOLOGIZE T
PHSEALF NT
PREENT HETI
MAINTAINEDIS, NSTAGR
URAR ANY DIREC.
SPENT ON MOBIL
SOCIAL MEDIA, IT IIMPORTN MENT G
MEISEXIS
SCIENTIFICK
CAK DIANRESPONSEJOSH
HERE IS A QUOTE FROM YOWN
Y.
WE MAKE FO
INEE TEEN GIRLS.R NS
CONSISTENT ACROSAL
THAT'S YOUY.
THE FEED HOW PEOPLE THSEWE CAN Y
BLS HAVE BEEN DOIN FOR YEFULL SD
PRODUCT
PROFE OYCHOLOGYY.OINS
CK FIRST SPOKE HYOU
WE HAD THE DIALOGUON MY RA
E.
YE HESITANT TO E
S OF
CORRIOOU
VEN ES'STEKNOWING ABOUT ATN IS L
E'P ANA L GROUP S RAND
WHDS UNEEATMENT OU GIVE UP
SOIAN
CI MEDIATHE CONT
P ORMAL  ANDE WHO HAVE C BAC SOA
INSTAGRAM.IESEPEC IE
THE BODYMAGE TROGR'RF A VERY AMN
N.
I'M GOING TO PUT I
THISNDAVPLAIN WHAT
IT IS YOURSELF,  IJO THE WAYI F
DIRECTLYTH SUBJE.
D IN THIS COLLABORATIVE GOOGLC?
>> YEAH, SO A FEO WES NDOU KNOW
THN TENSENTIONED ALL
OF TF TEENS IN M
THE MORE HF TEENS SPENT ON
MEDIA, THE MOY IT
CRISIS.EXAMPLE, TEE.USHER GOOGLE
OUBLED BETWE1  D T
IS INCREASE TE
YEARBEANDEMIC.
OBABLY NOT A CID
IME THATL
MEA TED TOE MUCH
REMO TTHK GRNDMARTPHONES
STD NG
RA-BASEDES
BECAME SO MUCHLAR.
IT IS COVID, I THE, IMATE GE
PUBLISHED --P YE
ON SCREEN.YOBL3 LE EXPLANATIONS
THAT'SERNATIVE NUM
I AM PUTTI T ON TH
OW.
OF THE GETEDE YOU RI
REARENTING
STYLE AND THE AGE OFEXPLAIN.
.
NT OUT THAT E REASON A OOT
L ISHAT
THEY'RST ON U.S.
THINGS L THE
LICHTINGS, IOUT SE IN DEPRESSIOD
IT SHOWS U INTERNATIONAL
TAY AFTER COUNTRY.E PPNTSSION AI
LONELI TN AROUND S TRUEHAT  COMO
S LIKE T
T SE BY
SS LIKELTO T L HAVE IDOBTHEY GOV
GENETID WHEN THEY WE
INIG. IJU GEN-Z LIVES.
IT IS NOT JU AUT
STYLE.
ACROSS ALLGET WE JUS
LONGERGR
TLDLL
BACK TOHERE WBEGIN.DS.
WHY N'T T?
SEEN WHAT YOHITE HAVE PUT TOG?
YOUNGER ERS BILL GRIET  LL GO IF
EENS, EVEN ON THE EDDER AKNE
THBAL AL, DRGE THA YOU.
M REACTION.OUNDS OD
CONVERSATION.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE WORLD OF
TE
SHORME PIOD JONATHAN'S BK LAST U
SAM  AE
SO,
NOW MADE NOTOO
INTERACTSEHUMBS WITH T T
SO YOUY, IT IS
ITST THEAREN